on est là les allemands nous
encerclaient au stéthoscope
viol de sa fille la démocrate
les eaux capturer tout l'équipage
tous ont été torturés
puis tuées
[Musique]
je suis à l'avs réussi à m'enfuir ils ne
vont pas
j'ai mis la vie de personnes innocentes
rocher on vous attendait depuis un petit
moment
j'ai alors réalisé qu'il ne s'agissait
plus de mois rapporte tout ce qu'on a en
couverture et bardage
tu sais qui c'est il s'agissait de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand que
vous appelez yan yan ball str tu as
l'air d'être doué avec des cartes
tu peux me montrer où est la suite
[Musique]
là c'est l'assiette c'est un long voyage
et
[Musique]